I'm going to begin this unit with an old problem known as the "water-pouring problem."
Here's what we're given: two glasses of water and we have a faucet in a sink,
which can be the source of as much water as we want.
Now, these glass are of different sizes.
I haven't drawn them that much different, but this one is 4 oz, and this one is 9 oz.
For those of you in the rest of the world besides the U.S., an ounce is about 30 mL.
Our goal is to measure out a specific amount of water.
What we want to have is 6 oz of water measured out.
Six ounces won't fit in this glass.
The idea is at the end want to have this glass filled with exactly 6 oz of water.
There's no gradated markers.
It's not like a function.graduated cylinder or measuring cup
where we have the measurements on the glass.
It wouldn’t be accurate enough to just eyeball it.
What we've got to do is we've got to figure out how to do that by
measuring out a precise amounts into the cups and pouring them off.
For example, if the goal had been 5 oz, then that would have been easy.
We'd just fill the 9 oz all the way up to the top,
and then pour the 9 oz into the 4 oz until the 4 oz is all the way full,
and then what would be remaining here because there's 9 altogether would be 5 in this glass.
Five ounces is easy. Six ounces is not as obvious how to get there.
The puzzle is to find a sequence of pouring actions, and the pouring can be
from one glass to another. It can go in the other direction.
It can go from the faucet into each of the glasses.
And it can go from the glasses down the drain.
Six different actions we can take, and we want to find a sequence of actions
that arrives at this goal of 6 oz.
Of course, we can generalize the problem and put any number rather than 9 and 4 and 6.
As usual, let's make our inventory of concepts that we're going to be dealing with.
We have the glass, and the glass has a capacity and a current level.
This glass would have capacity 9, current level 5.
We're also going to need collection of glasses probably--a pair of glasses.
I guess we can say that the pair of glasses and they're current levels
represents a complete state of the world.
We'll think of that as a state of the world.
Everything we need to know about where we are in the problem.
Then we have a goal that we're trying to reach.
We have the pouring actions--1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
That breaks down into emptying, filling, and transferring.
The transferring, I think, is a little bit tricky, because there are two ways to do it.
When we were transferring from the 9 oz into the 4 oz--
so we transfer from x to y--we can do that until y is full.
That's what happened here. The 4 oz was full.
Or we could do it until x is empty.
If we were starting to pour back 4 oz from here into an empty one, we could do it until it was empty.
Anything else in the inventory? Oh, well, we certainly need a notion of a solution.
A solution is going to be a sequence of steps--
to pour from here to here, then from here to the drain, then fill up, then pour again, and so on.
What this unit is really all about is techniques for finding these solutions,
which are sequences of steps.
Again, we're always talking about managing complexity in this class.
The complexity we're trying to manage here is a complexity